CHECKING ABBETT.
SO GOOD TO SEE YOU TONIGHT,
THANK YOU.
>> THINK IT.
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
DOESN'T JUST WRITE THAT TITLE
EXIST TO CONVEY INFORMATION BUT
TO WITHHOLD IT AND IN THIS WHIT
HOUSE THAT PRESS SECRETARY BANS
ANY REPORTER ASKING QUESTIONS
AND THAT INCLUDES AND ESPECIALL
INCLUDES PAYMENT DEEPER HE'S TH
MOST FAMOUS AND YOU WOULD SAY
FINEST REPORTER IN ALL OF AFRICA
, THAT MEANS THAT DOES NOT
WANT TO TALK TO HIM AT ALL SHE
HASN'T CALLED ON HIM AND MORE
THAN FOUR MONTHS, OUT THE WHITE
HOUSE SAYS THAT HE WILL NOT MEE
WITH SIMON AT TP UNTIL WHICH OF
COURSE MEANS NEVER.
HE IS WITH TODAY NEWS AFRICA
ENJOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
ON WHAT GROUNDS WILL SHE JUST
NOT MEET WITH YOU?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME, TUCKER.
THIS IS THE MOST WATCHED SHOW
AND I AM GLAD TO BE HERE.
YOU HAVE THE VOICE OF AFRICA IN
THE USA.
I LOVE THE U.S., I LOVE FREEDOM
I LOVE DEMOCRACY AND EVEN IF YO
PAID ME $100 MILLION TO MOVE TO
CHINA, I WOULD NOT MOVE TO CHIN
I LIKE TO BE IN THE U.S. BECAUS
THE IDEAL OF THE U.S. IS THE
IDEALS THAT THERE ARE MANY
THINGS THAT I LOVE AND THOSE AR
THE THINGS THAT MOST AFRICANS
ALSO LOVE FREIGHT I FEEL LIKE
SHE HAS NO CLUE WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN AFRICA.
SPREADING DISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION AGAINST THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT THAT THAT COMPETITIO
IS GOOD, BUT THEN, WHEN
COMPETITION COMES WITH
DESTROYING DEMOCRACY, AND THAT
BECOMES A PROBLEM AND SHE DID
THAT IS WHY SHE DISCRIMINATES
AGAINST ME.
SHE HASN'T CALLED ME FOR THE
PAST FOUR MONTHS SO LAST WEEK I
TRIED TO MEET WITH HER AND SHE
TOLD ME SHE WOULD ONLY MEET WIT
ME ON 2024, IT MAY BE.
>> I WONDER IF IT'S THE CASE
THAT SHE DOESN'T CALL ONION
BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T WANT TO HEA
ABOUT CHINESE INFLUENCE IN
AFRICA?
>> IS, I FEEL LIKE SHE DOESN'T
TAKE SERIOUS QUESTIONS, SHE
WANTS TO HAVE QUESTIONS THAT SH
HAS RECEIVED IN ADVANCE.
AND STAFF QUESTION.
MANY THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN
AFRICA, INCLUDING IMMIGRATION
FOR INSTANCE, HOW DOES IT MAKE
SENSE THAT AFRICANS WHO ARE HER
FOR INSTANCE, WHO CAME LEGALLY,
A PLIÉ FOR ASYLUM LEGALLY HAVE
TO WAIT FOR SIX YEARS FOR THEIR
CASES TO EVEN BE HEARD, AND
THERE ARE CASES THAT ARE NOT
HURT OF THE SIX MONTHS, BUT YOU
SEE PEOPLE JUST WALKING ACROSS
THE BORDER AND THEY HAVE ALL TH
BENEFITS, HOW IS THAT FAIR TO
AFRICANS?
>> IT SEEMS LIKE A COMPLETELY
REASONABLE QUESTION, AND YOU HA
THE AUTHORITY TO ASK A.
WE ARE ROOTING FOR YOU IN THE
WHITE HOUSE BRIEFING ROOM, WE
HOPE THEY WILL CHANGE THEIR
VIEWS AND STOP WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.